Jonathan looks like you're getting ready
for the World Cup
hi I'm actually training for the next
one 2022 watch out or early no well you
know I have to stay ready so that I
don't have to get ready fair fair
my name is Roy Costa welcome to another
episode of take five this is Jonathan
why don't you do yourself hi my name is
Jonathan Cole I'm a customer engineer
here at Google awesome what are we
doubling today Jonathan today we're
going to walk through multi cluster
ingress with Google kubernetes engine
very cool let's get started yep let's do
it on GC feed the nodes on your
kubernetes cluster could either all be
in one zone or across multiple zones in
a region and on these nodes you could be
running multiple services which needs to
expose to the outside world somehow and
for this you would use an ingress
resource and on GCP we implement that
using the Google cloud load balancer it
allows you to map HTTP requests to a
particular service or services running
on your nodes now with multi closet
ingress which is actually a new feature
it allows you to route your traffic
across multiple services across multiple
nodes it's a really powerful feature a
really cool feature so let's jump into
the demo I'm in my console now and
specifically in the google kubernetes
engine section and you can see I have
two clusters here that I've already
provisioned cluster 1 and cluster 2
running in u.s. East 4 and Europe West
one diving into one of the clusters we
can take a quick look at the
configuration it is a basic default
setup so 3 nodes running kubernetes 1.9
dot 7 this is essentially the defaults
right so nothing too fancy going on here
we can also take a look at the workloads
that are running on the cluster and we
see we have two workloads these are two
deployments running on the two different
clusters and they're both called zone
printer if we dive in to one of the
applications one of the deployments can
take a look at what the UI shows us that
shows us basic metrics but what's going
on with those workloads running on the
cluster or one particular cluster in
this case and we can see my set up that
it's just comprised of three different
pods all serving the same application
now we've also actually provisioned an
ingress resource beforehand which we'll
take a look at and
if you remember an ingress resource on
Google is provisioned using the Google
cloud load balancer which is what we're
going to navigate to and if we dive into
our Google cloud load balancer
implementation we can actually grab the
IP address that's going to be our IP
address that will actually use to
communicate with the services so we can
grab that IP address and go to our
browser and read ourselves to that
address and this is what are greeted
with we have the US flag and a nice
welcome message from Ashburn Virginia
that is the exact place where our
cluster is running it's in the US east
for a zone now what we want to do next
is simulate what would happen if one of
our clusters or the applications running
on those clusters falls over underneath
the hood G K clusters are actually
managed instance groups so we can
navigate to the manage instance Crusades
and actually simulate what this kind of
scenario will look like so if we set a
restart event to actually restart all of
the nodes this will kill what's running
right now the nodes will be drained and
that cluster for brief period will be
unavailable and so we've done that
hopefully in a few seconds we'll have a
cluster coming offline but soon to be
restarted so let's navigate back to the
browser and see what actually happens
now and after a few seconds success
we've been redirected to the belgium
zone that's here of quest one where our
second cluster is running with the same
application so this is pretty cool in a
normal scenario wherever your users are
trying to access your application from
they will actually be routed to the zone
that's closest to them this is a power
of multi cluster ingress so what do you
think we it was amazing Jonathan thank
you thank you thanks everyone for
watching remember to click to subscribe
and share video and if you are working
on any cool projects and you want to
connect with us click on the link in the
description below thanks everyone
thank you
[Music]